after tobias menzies is no stranger to
success in Game of Thrones
he played Edmure Tully the groom at the
famous red wedding his dual roles as
Frank and Jonathan Black Jack Randall in
Outlander earned him a Golden Globe
nomination and now Menzies is taking
over the role of Prince Phillip in the
hit Netflix show the crown this is him
and the real Prince Philip side-by-side
look at the resemblance in this scene
his character signs up the family for a
documentary film yes it's a documentary
film journey do you it means no actually
no artifice just the real thing like one
of those wild night folks
I like this yes he said this time we are
the endangered species exactly follow
all of us and our daily lives to prove
to everyone out there what we in here
already know what's that well how hard
we all work
what good value we represent how much we
deserve the taxpayers money tobias
menzies joins us now to buy us good
morning welcome thank you so much so
this is a really interesting role
because season three of the crown is a
continuation of a story that people have
been watching for two prior seasons but
it's a whole new cast yes if you were
now Prince Phillip in middle age right
yes so it's an unusual muscle theatrical
gesture for a very well known TV show
you're highly acclaimed to change
everyone in the cast why was it
appealing to you second why was it
appealing to you to take it on Peters
writing is fantastic and that it really
is the sort of bedrock of I think the
success of the show I think it's a very
interesting very interesting man
that there's a lot of complexity so
periods are sort of acting challenge
it's rich there's also the sort of the
technical challenge of the voice and you
know the how he moves
everyone is obviously he's been you know
famous for his life you do quite a lot
of studying to get into the role as I
understand it you just
growing up in the UK we're not
particularly a watcher of the Royals you
in fact you would turn away during the
Queen's address on Christmas Day start
out you here yeah I'm afraid yeah I'm I
hope I don't get fired but yeah I mean I
wasn't yes my family weren't the
internet way inclined my mum would sort
of not be but a big fan of watching
their the Queen's speech on it on a
Christmas morning so so yeah I had to
learn quite a bit when I sort of started
working on the wrong did your respect
for them increases you learn more
absolutely yeah I mean I think whatever
your political stripe I think you can't
question the dedication and service that
they have given to to our country I
talked to Matt Smith who of course
played the younger Prince Philip in the
first two seasons and and he said he
actually grew quite quite sympathetic to
the character and then there's also this
challenge of playing someone who's alive
and can actually could call you up one
day and say yeah I know
I imagine the idea of them here with him
actually sitting and watching me doing
him I mean your brain starts to fizz a
bit I think yeah the the technical
challenge is big I do have I did come to
have some sympathy for that life I think
it must be challenging it's highly
ceremonial you're talking to a lot of
rooms where people are nervous and
tongue-tied and yes it's a high quantity
of small talk and that's something I
would be very bad at the actual royal
family is facing a lot of media scrutiny
especially these days you yeah you know
that Prince Andrew just spoke out when
you look at the idea of addressing that
even in this new season and the media's
role and how the royal family is
portrayed what are your thoughts I guess
is you're watching someone from that
royal family actually speak out in real
time yes the relevance of it is striking
I mean we have an episode in season 3
episode 4 which is absolutely about the
family's relationship with the media and
Prince Philip attempting just open that
out and engage with the media more and
that's obviously been continuing all
these years with you know very mixed
results it's been a real challenge to
that family and obviously this most
recent version of it with Andrews
interview which you know is
feels like problematic invests
diplomatic way of putting it there was a
small controversy last season that I
think points to a bigger issue that I'd
love your thoughts on so so Claire Foy
who played the young queen was being
paid less than Matt Smith who played
Prince Philip yeah and I think that was
corrected by the end and now in this
season as I understand it you're being
paid less than the Queen this is true
yeah the bigger issue though is about
pay equity in Hollywood and in these
sorts of roles do you think enough is
being done is there enough transparency
can we see the problem wrap our arms
around and is it being fixed the honest
answer is I don't know the answer to
that in terms of whether it's being
fixed you're right there's a lot of it's
quite hard to for it to be a very open
conversation There is obviously
complexity because people bring
different experiences different
audiences to a show and that is partly
reflected in pay but I feel like we've
still got some way to go in terms of
addressing yeah the gender pay gap for
sure well here the new rule is on on the
crown anyways no one makes more than the
Queen no one makes me alright well we're
very excited the crown is back tobias
menzies thanks so much for being with us
this morning you can stream season three
of the crown on Netflix now